If you play around a bit with this algorithm what you will see is this.
Each time that this loop here runs, it puts at least 1 of the vertices from
the minimum vertex cover into its solution.
So the correct answer is this. Let me illustrate this.
If you take any edge here, so the algorithm starts out fresh, and you take any edge
from this graph, it's impossible to take an edge where not at least 1 of the points
is in the minimum vertex cover.
Say we take this edge here, then "Take 2" would put these 2 vertices here into its solution,
and 1 of those vertices is actually part of the minimum vertex cover.
Or if the "Take 2" algorithm say uses this edge here, then we even have a better case,
because both of the vertices that it now chooses to be part of its solution,
are actually also part of a optimum solution. And this works for all edges.
No matter what edge you choose here, you will always have at least 1 endpoint
that is part of a minimum vertex cover.